Speaker 1: When Republicans start to control
things, politics gets very stupid in the
United States. That's something we are very
quickly learning and we have a new scandal.
Is that even the right word? A scandal involving
classified documents and Joe Biden when he was
vice president? Let me tell you what's going
on. And then let me tell you what these right
wing clowns are saying. CNN reports classified
documents from Joe Biden's time as vice president
discovered in a private office. What exactly
happened? Here's a CNN report explaining it.
Speaker 2: These were documents the White House
says, that were found by the former president,
by the current president's attorneys in November
as they were closing out an office that the former
vice President Biden, of course, had set up
in office with the University of Pennsylvania
at the PEN Biden Center here in Washington.
And they were closing out these offices when
they found what they say were fewer than a dozen
documents that were labeled as classified. Now,
a number of these documents were also subject to
the Presidential Records Act. And according to the
White House, these were now turned over to the
National Archives, which has asked the Justice
Department to look into it. Now, we're told now,
Jake, that the that the attorney general, Merrick
Garland, has asked the U.S. attorney in Chicago
to conduct a review of these document documents,
which is a standard process that they would
go through. This is akin to the process that
happened after the National Archives asked the
Justice Department to look into these classified
materials that were recovered from Mar a Lago from
the former President Trump's residence. So it is a
process that the Justice Department recently went
through, obviously, with Donald Trump. Of course,
the difference here is that according to the
White House, it was the president's legal team
that reached out to narrow to turned over these
documents as opposed to with Trump, who fought
for months and months not to turn over documents
that the archives said needed to be turned over.
Speaker 1: So that's one critical difference.
But there are actually a number of other critical
differences. Misplacing and stealing documents
are not, in fact, the same thing. Now investigate
everything. Investigate this. I don't know anyone
on the left who's saying don't investigate,
but misplacing and stealing documents are
dramatically different things. It doesn't
matter to a lot of these right wingers who are
immediately saying things like, for example,
what Marjorie Taylor GREENE said last night on
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson's program.
Speaker 3: Well, this is a huge story.
It's very serious. As a matter of fact,
Joe Biden conceivably stole those documents.
Speaker 1: Conceivably is doing some heavy
lifting in that statement.
Speaker 3: What people need to
understand is the president of the United States
is the only one that can declassified documents,
not the vice president, for Joe Biden
to steal documents, possession of them.
This is a serious investigation. And the
communist at an era can't hide it anymore.
Speaker 1: And now there's no communists at Nara.
Speaker 3: Garland and the Department of Justice.
They have to be held accountable if they
don't treat Joe Biden exactly the same
way they're treating President Trump.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they should be treated
the same way in that the facts should
be evaluated by law enforcement. Now,
it's really important to understand this
story. These documents were in a locked closet.
Joe Biden's attorneys found them, immediately,
contacted the National Archives. Remember,
with Trump, it was throw all this crap in a box,
take it to my house at Mar a Lago. Here you had
documents that were misplaced. And as soon as
they were found, rather than trying to hide and
keep the documents, Biden's lawyers proactively
reach out to the National Archives. Dramatic
difference from what we saw with Trump. And then
they were handed over to the archives the next day
as opposed to fighting for months, lying
and claiming that you turned them over. You
didn't being caught on tape moving them between
locations while still not turning them over,
barely comparable. I'm consistent,
investigated. It's being investigated. I
love that. Let's investigate this. And hey, you
know what? If Joe Biden's house needs to have
a search, a search warrant served as a result.
Go ahead and do it. I'm not getting in the way.
But of course, we know that the circumstances
are completely different now. It doesn't matter
to them, to people like Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
to whoever. It doesn't matter. They want to say,
hey, this is the exact same thing Trump did,
and he's being treated differently. Actually,
he's being treated the same. It's being
investigated. It's the circumstances that are
completely different. I hope you're all buckled
in for two years of this because this is what
the next two years are going to be like and it'll
be Hunter Biden. Maybe they'll go back to Hillary
and Benghazi. They might investigate Obama's
tan suit. It's going to be that sort of stuff.
And when Marjorie Taylor GREENE is shifting into
being seen as a sort of de facto spokesperson for
the center of power of the Republican Party, you
know, it's going to get really stupid. Tomorrow,
6 p.m. Eastern is the next David Pakman Show
town hall. I hope you will join me. We will
be streaming live. I will be taking questions
and comments from everybody in the audience.
We will give priority to our website members and
you can sign up at join Packman dot com in order
to get instant access to the bonus show.
Speaker 4: O the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And you will get priority access
to talking to me during the town hall.
Speaker 4: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Well, you. Some people want
to talk to me, Alex. Okay. And we'll be
talking to some of them tomorrow. We'll take
a quick break and be back right after this.